good afternoon everyone as you can see
from my first slide I'm going to talk
today about what I'm calling making
MOOCs matter but before I get on to
MOOCs I couldn't resist beginning also
with my favorite dome in Rome which you
see on the screen just to make the point
that the Pantheon dome in Rome is more
massive than any MOOC I wanted to begin
I wanted to begin by explaining to you
I'm actually not going to talk about the
history of open Yale courses are all
learned although i will mention them in
passing but i wanted to say more about
why i agreed to teach a MOOC and the
reason I agreed to teach a MOOC is
really because it's the law it's the
logical next step for me to take because
I've been doing online education yell at
Yale now for 13 years and I've been
doing it in large part to try to enhance
my own pedagogy and in turn to have it's
actually hard to see this from from here
so maybe I should create a filming
problem okay I'm having a little trouble
seeing the screen so it forces me to
have to look down which I wasn't
intending to have to do but I will do so
in turn I've used my Yale courses is an
incubator to create online resources for
a broader audience so for me the two are
inseparable I created three online
courses for all learn the first the
first online program that we did at Yale
and have taught one of those courses oh
that would great yes I much prefer so I
created three online courses for all
learn and have taught one of them my
course called eek law dia women in
ancient Rome as an undergraduate seminar
and I've done that by flipping the
classroom which is a term you probably
all been hearing about that positive
experience led me to rebuild my on
campus undergraduate lecture courses to
incorporate an online forum and other
new digital resources these were in turn
used by me to develop my concept for
open Yale courses I'm just trying to
make the point about the way in which my
on-campus teaching and my my thinking
about online teaching really were very
much part and parcel of the same thing
so I these were in turn used by me to
develop as I mentioned my concept for
open Yale courses two years into the
open your courses project my Roman
architecture undergraduate lecture
course was recorded for open Yale
courses so in some my pedagogical
approach has long been that teaching
well online and teaching well in person
on campus are two sides of the same coin
essentially
so I want to divide this into past that
was passed and now present and then I'm
going to talk about spring 2014 and then
about the future so now for my MOOC
where I am now for my MOOC on Roman
architecture I am developing original
materials based on some i have used on
campus and also adding others that are
entirely new i am using my previously
recorded open Yale courses lectures on
Roman architecture to teach a entire
semester online to teach an entire
semester online for the core as a MOOC
on Coursera the lectures are chapter
eyes into 15 to 20 minute segments and
will be accompanied by new quizzes
assessments and online discussion that
is being created for the course and I
want to use that MOOC to innovate not
only in the online venue but also to
innovate in my on-campus course at the
same time so as I began to think about
how I was going to structure this and
how I was going to bring something new
into the conversation I decided that I
would concentrate on what I've ended up
calling for myself my five big my five
new Big Ideas three of these ideas are
deeply embedded in the subject matter of
my course Roman architecture and to me
there the potentially most exciting
things that I'm going to be doing in the
course of teaching this next semester
but I'm not going to talk about them
today because like the Romans who
favored architectural surprises I'm
saving those three for the January
launch of the MOOC I really don't want
to talk about them now because they're
still in development and I'd like to
wait and and and share them in January
but since I'm an art historian and
nothing there's nothing an art historian
is nothing without images as I note i
would let me let me introduce let me let
me show you a few images just to
introduce you to my subject matter and
to give you a better sense of what i
mean by a
Roman surprise so this is the pantheon
I'm going to show you a few images of
the Pantheon because the pantheon as you
can see it here this is a reconstruction
of what it would have looked like in
antiquity and you can see it was fronted
by a large open rectangular space now if
you look at that open rectangular space
you'll see that when you enter into the
courtyard all you would actually see is
the front of the temple you would have
seen the columns and you would have seen
the triangular pediment that's
essentially all and that's all they
wanted you to see when you walked in and
what you were seeing it essentially was
a traditional Greek or at ruskin temple
it looked exactly like those two did but
if you get up closer and this is of
course what the Pantheon looks like
today it has in front of it a more
recent fountain beautiful fountain you
can get a sense you have to imagine
those two colonnades one on either side
you can again get a sense of what you
would have seen from the front which is
a series of collars and inscription
triangular pediment and then an attic
behind here is a view when you get even
closer you see a view of what remains of
the pediment the building is very well
preserved and it mentions the name of
the dedicated Marcus Agrippa coast tear
TM console for the third time made it he
was a son of lucious all of that is
specified by his very bizarre because we
know that this is a building that was
built in the 2nd century and and Marcus
Agrippa lived in the age of Augustus so
there's a mystery there of course and to
solve the mystery I can explain to you
that when Hadrian commit when hate when
trajan and Hadrian rebuilt and
commissioned the Pantheon they decided
to honor Agrippa as the first because he
had built a Pantheon himself earlier on
that same site so we see we see here a
view of the doorway into the building
this is what I meant by a surprise when
you go into the doorway you actually
begin to get a glimpse
the fact that the inside of the building
doesn't look anything like the outside
of the building when you go in what you
see is this you see a spectacular dome
that completely transforms your sense of
what this building was in an amazing way
and that's the sort of thing that I was
trying to express was just that I would
like to save my domes in a sense until
January and concentrate on other things
today but what I do want to do i am
happy to share two of those two of those
big ideas today or at least what i think
our big ideas because i think they
actually speak to essentially what the
theme what Craig is set out as the theme
for today which is this interaction
between where this this importance of
concentrating on teaching at Yale and
the way in which online teaching can
also help enhance that so I'd like to
mention those two ideas that are going
to speak to that in particular because
they really do offer additional ways to
explore how online teaching can enhance
education at Yale while offering Yale
educational materials to motivated
learners around the world so again i'm
going to give you two of those points
i'm going to call 14 since i'm not
revealing one two and three so for I
will teach my on-campus and online
courses at the same time in order to
create pedagogical synergy globally
between the Yale classroom and the world
so in the spring term i'm going to start
the course on the Coursera platform at
the same time that I start my course
here at Yale and I'm going to be
teaching it for the entire semester in
in conjunction i will give live lectures
in my yale campus course as I usually do
and we'll use the recorded lectures
online with quizzes interspersed that
I'm building for the Coursera MOOC the
quizzes though could also voluntarily be
taken by Yale students and I think
actually there might be some who would
find that helpful and they would also
have this Yale students would also have
access to the kind of critical thinking
questions the quote that I
creating also for the for the MOOC and i
think that the feedback that we would
get from both of those parties could be
quite revelatory and i look forward to
seeing what that will be and i think it
could be helpful not only to me
personally but to the progress that we
make over time with these kinds of
explorations there will be online
discussion forums in both places with
some some opportunity for voluntary
interaction between the two groups I
haven't sorted out exactly how I'm going
to do that yet and I think it will
probably be voluntary for students at
Yale but I'm hoping that there will be
some will be interested enough to
participate in that and then as the the
fifth I'd the fifth item the other one
of the two big ideas that I'm talking
about today in order to enhance and
broaden the educational experience I am
involving an international team of
community moderators who come not only
from the United States but also from
countries that were part of the
Mediterranean wide Roman Empire and will
be able to provide timely on the spot
observations I had that experience when
I was doing all learn and was teaching a
course on Roman women I had an online
instructor was helping me do that and
she was leading the sections but every
so often I would come on and interact
and it was amazing because we had people
all over the world taking it at the same
time and if an issue came up for example
about something in Rome a detail about
something the person who happened to be
the related to someone who worked at the
embassy in Rome said oh I'll go down
tomorrow to the Vatican and I'll take a
look and I'll get back to everybody so
it does expand expands possibilities for
those kinds of conversations that I
think having those those not only a
broad base of students from different
countries around the world but also
community moderators and some of those
community moderators will be Yale alumni
and the online involvement of that group
of those yellow alumni I think will also
benefit of course not only the students
taking the MOOC but also the students
taking the course on campus at the same
with regard to the future I want to make
some remarks this afternoon that are my
remarks alone I'm not speaking for the
University this is just my thinking
about the future and as I see it now for
online education having thought about it
for so many years and been involved in
it in some with so in so many ways and I
would just say first of all that
education has been disrupted off campus
and on campus I think there's no turning
back now whatever education will be and
none of us know exactly what it's going
to be it's going to be different of that
I'm sure but I can't help but think of
my Romans because the Romans did exactly
the same thing with Roman architecture
they disrupted Greek and Etruscan
architecture using a new technology
their new technology was concrete
construction and through concrete
construction they completely transformed
not only Roman architecture but the
entire history of architecture so I
think we're actually on the cusp of
something similar to that with regard to
education I think we should always
remember Yale's mission yells stated
mission is the creation and
dissemination of knowledge with which we
are all involved yells other mission is
to train leaders in all disciplines
including education and i think there's
absolutely no question that we at yale
in whatever forms it is have to continue
to lead an education personally I think
that MOOCs matter because they are the
current coin of the realm and that realm
will surely evolve who knows what it
will be exactly six months from now a
year from now but we at Yale can't shape
that evolution without being part of
that evolution so I'm doing a MOOC in
part for that reason to make MOOCs
matter as we invent the future of
education at Yale and beyond and I
actually hope there is some students in
the in the audience today student
leaders who might want to partner with
me on this and join me in history of art
H SAR 252 this spring thank you
you